if you identify something you think is
both the problem and
the best approach
and you're serious then you should try
and invest a lot of energy getting
people on board to say yeah let's do
this thing right and this is actually a
complaint i have about a lot of modern
life now which is right now it's almost
impolitic or unpopular to actually do
the thing like where where where
talk about the thing oh yeah like we
talk about the thing like that that's
smart and savvy you could point at it
and be like oh yeah polarization that's
a problem now and we could all nod and
be like you write books about it too
yeah yeah and then if you're like hey
i'm going to do something about it it's
like oh no i can't do anything with that
guy yeah so
um so so then the way i'm wired is like
okay
i see something that needs to be done
someone should do it i'm a someone i'm
actually in this case the most logical
someone in some respect so i should do
it
[Music]
[Music]
welcome
to forward with andrew and zach and
whoever else uh it's a blast to be
kicking it off and there has been a lot
of
news being made this past week where my
book came out on tuesday i announced on
monday that i am leaving the democratic
party which i guess some people knew but
i made it official i signed the
paperwork and changed my registration to
independent
and that does require us talking a
little bit about
why i did it how it felt you know i'm
i'm happy to unpack this uh but zach
what is your relationship with political
parties did were your parents political
do you grow up in a particular
environment
i grew up uh
slightly conservative my parents
i think like bob dole more than more
than they like bill clinton
but um i was really interested in
politics but i was always i always
consider myself moderate um i voted i
registered
whichever wherever i was living so when
i graduated college i was in north
carolina before that when i was in
college i registered wherever i could
vote in the primaries i thought would be
the most interesting so uh does that
mean you've been a republican i've been
republican and democrat yeah um i was
republican new york i thought the
republican primaries are more fun here
um the democrat one's usually already
decided um
anyway
so yeah i've been a moderate so this is
like no shock to me but as we are
recording this andrew you're trending
this is monday
record is monday at four o'clock
eastern time you're trending on twitter
which is fun always a fun day
yes it's i mean it's been a very
interesting exercise
switching uh to independent so i i wrote
a statement about my own background with
parties where i registered as a democrat
in the mid 90s
and have been a steady democrat ever
since and i haven't really
questioned it too hard because in part
because no i live in new york city and i
think
democrats are fairly
much the norm
here very much and
it was a real
experience just signing that paperwork
because i did feel like something lifted
or changed in my mind even though it's
really
strange because i wanted to i could just
re-register as a democrat five minutes
later and like nothing you know i mean
like it sort of you know
nothing permanent has been done not that
i plan on doing that because i actually
kind of like the the new world of uh
being an independent and then i wrote a
statement talking about why i'm leaving
and i'm leaving because i think that
there is a more compelling
need
of systemic reform
than there is anything else that
polarization is going to
literally kill us
and
and so i want to
build the anti-polarization movement
around common sense solutions but also a
process that would be more genuinely
lower case d democratic
uh yeah and and the the reaction has
been
i'd say you know relatively
positive in some quarters and then very
negative in others and then the negative
quarters seem to be
pretty consistently democrats who are
definitely
um
uh and the strange thing is and i put
this in like a like on a subtweet it's
like it really seems strange to accuse
someone of opportunism for doing
something that almost certainly will end
up
um
diminishing one's like general
like
um
[Music]
i suppose
acceptability or something along those
lines it's like a very strange basket
where it's like huh
um you don't like it because you think
it's going to be
somehow self-serving but because this is
a fairly
common sentiment then you know it'd be
nonsensical for me to do something like
this
for self-serving reasons like you know
it like the only reason to do it would
be if i thought it was the right thing
to do which i do you've never been
have you ever considered yourself
there's like i'm a democrat or a
republican but then there's like i'm
team dem you know what i'm saying like
uh they don't call yourself team den but
your
democrats do no wrong or political
fandom or i've actually actually wrote a
like a small paper on this in college
about how people root for the democrats
or republicans same way they root for
the red sox the yankees it's very very
tribal jonathan heights says something
similar in his book the righteous mind
he talks about if you want to understand
politics you go to a college football
game yeah so you know um
and it's
the analogy to me is i'm a buffalo bills
fan we got beat up by tom brady for 20
plus years it doesn't matter
what you would tell me facts logic
evidence the alternative i think brady
sucks and that's and he's obviously the
greatest quarterback of all time but
does it no evidence is going to change
that because he just tortured us right
um or i'm a bills fan and that's kind of
what you see but you've never actually
been that you've been you've always been
like a logic math guy he's logical here
most of your friends are democrat your
social you've been socially liberal for
probably ever ever yeah um
and and same generally speaking um so
so it's not a
i guess it's interesting here you say
that because
it still felt like a breakup
um it it did feel like more of a breakup
even than maybe i would have anticipated
which is odd given that again i've been
a registered democrat for 26 years so i
suppose it's a fairly long-standing
relationship
you talked about crystal like some of
the democrats that reach out to you and
things like that but so i don't want to
unpack that too much we just did an
episode of that
on monday
today i thought would be fun
given that you're trending on twitter
there's a whole bunch of like real
questions or let's call it i'm gonna
call them the shitty
questions from the twitter trolls or
just public outrage when things like
this happen
um particularly from the left but
they're all over the map um and i wanted
to i think it'd be fun to have the real
thing like this happens i'm sorry
whatever
um
but i thought it'd be real and human to
ask you them on a personal level as a
friend sure man behind the scenes so
like the one comment you get a lot is
why that what the hell is andrea doing
is this just a money grab like oh i see
he's got a book coming out he's just
doing this to sell books
um
again again a very very odd thing yes
help us walk us through that logic then
you know it's actually sort of the
reverse zach where i wrote this book
over a period of months in 2020 and i
came to the conclusion that our system
is turning us against each other and
that you need a dynamic change and you
need
an incentive switch in the form of open
primaries and rank choice voting and
then i thought well how do you actually
achieve that because there are people in
organizations that are trying to make
that happen on the ground but there
isn't really a whole lot of popular
energy despite the fact that i'm sure
this is
to me
one of the only real things we could do
that would bring us back from the
cliff
and so i concluded well
someone should definitely start some
kind of
movement around
trying to reduce polarization and
implement open primaries in my choice
voting that would release or unlock both
our current legislators from their
messed up incentives but also would
unlock different political points of
view right and oh by the way make us
much more resilient to authoritarianism
because right now you have just one
point of failure and then if that party
succumbs and all of a sudden you're in
you know a
nightmarish uh
dystopia so
not to say i mean you know what i'm
describing is
um
is if our
democracy does
end up uh succumbing to authoritarianism
which right now is a much more real
possibility unfortunately because of the
way our system set up so
in the book i draw these conclusions
and then i conclude to say okay we
should do this
and then
being i think a reasonable actor i don't
think it's appropriate for me
frankly one of the most realistic
figures who could do this to say and
someone should do this bookend and i'm
now going to do something else like if
you identify something you think is both
the problem and
the best approach
and you're serious then you should try
and invest a lot of energy getting
people on board to say yeah let's do
this thing right and uh this is actually
a complaint i have about a lot of modern
life now which is right now it's almost
impolitic or unpopular to actually do
the thing like we're worried about talk
about the thing oh yeah like we talk
about the thing like that that's smart
and savvy you could point at it and be
like oh yeah polarization that's a
problem now and we could all nod and be
like you write books about it too yeah
yeah and then if you're like hey i'm
going to do something about it's like oh
no i can't do anything with that guy
yeah yeah so
um so so then the way i'm wired is like
okay
i see something that needs to be done
someone should do it i'm a someone i'm
actually in this case the most logical
someone in some respects so i should do
it
and i think that there's like also a
strangeness around the timeline which is
people think oh you know ran for office
and lost you're doing this thing it's
like well actually
i'm fast but there's no way i could
write a book in four weeks you know what
i mean i mean like this book
like like this book was written and the
ideas in the track laid
uh
last year summer yeah right yeah and so
when i drew this conclusion i was like
okay how are we gonna make this happen
and then i saw a couple of paths to do
so and here we are
[Music]
we're all human we all get down
sometimes and one of the things that a
lot of us do is nothing
which is not what you want to do so
what's something that fits your needs is
confidential is convenient so where do
you turn
there is a service that we recommend
here at the pod it's better help and
this is connecting you to a professional
licensed therapist you can talk
confidentially you can ping them anytime
you need them
and they'll get you on the schedule it's
convenient it's professional it's
affordable it is awesome we swear by it
we want you to be happier we want
ourselves to be happier
and
if you go there right now you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting
our sponsor betterhelp.com yang join
over 1 million people who have improved
their mental health again that's
betterhelphelp.com
them they're going to help you
[Music]
can you
what are your thoughts on this starting
an actual third party breaking up the
democratic party as one of the most
prominent democrats in the country
objectively speaking according to a
number of sources yougov is my favorite
one with like live polling
um
starting a third party is objectively a
bad way to sell a book would you agree
with that statement i do i think oh as i
do because if you look at it
first uh who are the press outlets and
the book buyers like it would tend to be
folks who are very comfortable with the
democratic narrative yep and
so
that it would be actually unwise for
someone to make a public break from the
democratic party
when their book comes out and you have
friends that are democrats both business
side and elected official kamala pete
biden in the administration who
theoretically could tweet and help
promote and help you like hype it up and
if you're doing this those are no longer
assets right the democratic party is an
asset to help you sell the book as well
so that's which just true it's probably
more true of the media outlets but yes
yeah um
so all right checking that box the other
one i got which you kind of just touched
on was that i um
you're doing this because you lost two
primaries people say that that's what's
trending on twitter a lot and i think i
want i'll say this like you had written
this book before you had even decided to
run for mayor of new york yeah that's
accurate uh
so uh it actually derailed all book
plans when you did decide to run yes for
mayor um
now
a lot of a lot of i think average people
when they think about
a third party you're like won't that
just spoil
the election for my preferred candidate
let's go whatever team i'm on let's say
don't that just make it easier for trump
to win or won't that just make it easier
for biden to win you know it does all
seem to be coming from one side whereas
the democrats yeah it's going to help
trump win i i personally haven't seen a
lot of oh this is going to really help i
didn't sew it up
and
no i i think that it's a function of the
fact that democrats
very much have like an anti-trump view
of the world and then think that if i
draw any votes then they would be
also in this non-trump camp because
they've kind of caricatured all trump
voters as
uh both monolithic and
uh very unreasonable
and that the case doesn't make sense of
the numbers i mean even when i was
running in a democratic primary 42
percent of my supporters they weren't
sure they're going to support the
democratic nominee which means that a
lot of them were independents or
republicans if you look at the desire
for a third party it's actually
significantly higher among republicans
than it is among democrats so if you
were to start a third party you would
probably draw from republicans more than
democrats
but like you said before a lot of this
stuff isn't fact based it's just tribal
it's just
one team saying oh you're going to help
the other team win and blah blah and you
could present facts to the contrary but
that's not part of the calculation
i guess
my thought is what would you say to
someone who's in the tribe on one side
or the other that has a visceral
reaction to this that's like well screw
you andrew yang like what about like
can't believe you're leaving my party or
like what would you say
for a doubter hater for those who are
listening maybe you have some doubts or
have friends that are going to have that
reaction or not be interested in that
sort of thing
what i would ask is do we think that
things are working on the track we're on
right now
i'm going to suggest that the current
situation isn't working for democrats
independents or republicans right and so
what is the real solution the path
forward is it to try and get in there
and eke out another marginal win or is
it to try and figure out why we're
literally
driving ourselves and each other
into
madness
and fix it and i'm going to suggest the
latter is just a much more
rational approach
you know i i mean i understand where
some people look at it and say hey no
spoiler
third party blah blah blah
and then part of me is like okay
so that's true based upon our current
binary
plurality voting system right would you
be happy if we just changed it to rank
choice voting and open primaries and
then there's no spoiler effect and then
some people
some people don't understand that so
that's you know on us to try and help
explain it to them and then the next
would be like well let's say you
actually control the apparatus of
government if you want you can make this
change and then no more spoiler effect
problem solved so to me that's where i'd
like to lead people
uh and it's just going to take a lot of
work because you know people don't
really think in these terms a lot of
them and that's what i want the forward
party to be is i was joking with someone
where the forward party is going to be
the approximately 10
of americans who actually respond more
to reason than any other form of appeal
political or otherwise
and one of the things i'm confident in
is that we don't need 51 percent of
people
we need
let's call it 10 to 15 percent and if
you have 10 to 15 in the middle of
uh
a polarized nation the way it is right
now you actually can do a world of good
right uh and so that that's one of the
things i learned and i talk about in the
book is that my language is like its own
political language for people who just
really like facts
is this uh i think this is an accurate
statement i want to get your thoughts on
this it's not the headlines are going to
say andrew yang starts third party
andrew yang's breaking up the democratic
party yada yada
but it's not just that andrew yang is
starting an organization to break the
duopoly with a large set
of relatively simple reforms to fix it
it's less almost about the party it's
more about the party as a vessel to
restructure democracy is that
that accurate statement yeah it is i
want to make our democracy work better
and
there are some people say oh why don't
you just do that within the democratic
party and i just don't believe that's
realistic when you're going to try and
operate in red and blue states alike
and you can be a registered democrat and
be
part of the forward party you can be a
registered republican be part of the
forward party you can be registered
independent and i and
this should be an inclusive popular
movement because most of us should
realize that hey this stuff's not
working and it's designed not to work
it's actually designed to put us at each
other's throats and think that this
person's my mortal enemy and we can feel
like it we can feel
that unfortunately it's working like the
system's working in the sense that we
feel worse than ever we feel more
divided than ever
and so again what is a rational fix uh i
and one thing i'm excited about with you
zach is i want this podcast and the
forward party generally to be this
positive uplifting unifying
both
organization and movement but also
messages because so much of our
messaging out there in the world right
now is so
dark and
angry and doom and gloom
uh and
i had a conversation with van jones uh
today actually
and the the tough part of where we are
right now is that if reasonable people
act rationally we are sunk
you know what i mean like like if
everyone just does what their incentives
say to do we're doomed
and and the simplistic view of the world
is oh it's because there's some really
really bad people in there pulling the
strings and then van and i were like no
we only wish it were so because if it
were so then you could get in there and
have them
do something different and stop
something but it's worse than that it's
that we're in the midst of
a system
that is going to
grind us up
uh and make reasonable people act very
very unreasonably
and people on the outside will look at
and say oh you know it's the new group's
fault it's like well actually the new
group will also act rationally
[Laughter]
it's
like so that this is the darkness it's
either very uplifting or very very dark
um but
if you want to fix it you have to
actually try and amend the incentives
there's really no other way
you're going to be doing a podcast
circuit and
um trying to do all of them nothing like
home baby though nothing like home yes
so you'll learn more about this we've
covered a lot on the crystal ball
episode you haven't heard that either
but a couple personal questions on this
because i think it's interesting to ask
honestly
if you weren't doing if you weren't
gonna do this what would you be doing
right like is this something that's
innate and um kind of almost instinctual
to you or were you weighing other
options before you dove into this i know
you've been thinking about it for a
while because you wrote it a while but
uh
if it wasn't a third party
where was your head at
i felt like i owed the people that have
supported me
uh an honest solution that i believed in
and then i owed them
my attempt at making it happen at its
highest level and you know if you were
to line up people who could successfully
start a third party um i would be
somewhere on the list
now
anyone who thinks that this seems like a
financially prudent thing to do is you
know frankly
not very smart or reasonable because
there are probably a thousand
ways you could
uh
make a living that are
[Laughter]
like
you know much
less of a headache than trying to
um rejuvenate our democracy and
um but put an end to this dysfunctional
duopoly that really and our duopoly just
makes no sense on the face of it as soon
as you take a step back and i think
about you're like wait a minute like why
would we set up set this up no other
country has it like this literally none
of them i mean besides maybe some
uh authoritarian or i mean then they
don't maybe they just have one system
but yeah you like we did i did some
research for uh like a like a talk you
were giving i was diving in the numbers
to fact check some things and we're
we're it man the duopoly here
because we figured it out and look the
uk has a ton of problems too right but
your point when there's more parties
like if you have a problem like social
media that's inflaming certain opinions
it's less of a blow when you have four
or five parties right it's less of a
it's not that it's not half the country
or both and that's in our case both
sides are actually just getting
disinflamed so
yeah so when you ask like well you know
what what do i do i mean i'm going to do
everything i can to help our country to
the best of my ability until i get very
very clear indication that either the
country is back on its feet in a great
way and i can run off of the sunset and
you know like
relax and read a book um or um yeah
that's it really i mean i'm just gonna
keep on trying i don't know what the or
is i mean um like as long as i have an
opportunity to try and do it i'll do it
but i i will say on a personal level
i think a lot of people who who know me
know this
like it's not like i'm someone who just
loves politics for the sake of politics
it's not like i'm someone who loves
being in the public eye for the sake of
being in the public eye but you know
like like everything i do is just to try
and accomplish various goals and if
there were
other
people
that would make it happen i would just
be clapping on the side like i don't
really have much of an ego about this
stuff
[Music]
the cavalry's not coming i agree with
you on that like we talked about this
being the episode we've been talking
about
we thought we're great at time with
problems
we're great we're great at pointing out
bad guys for said problems but no one's
really great at solving anything so i do
respect
that you've
just jumped in here you're like well if
no one's gonna do it i'm gonna effing do
it right and you know the great thing
zack is i i can feel like it's going to
be a lot of fun you know like there it
is the optimist
where
again
we can say the things that are on our
minds that
everyone knows uh to be true except no
one's allowed to say them for whatever
reason i mean uh you know we can have a
good time we can make jokes we can when
you're part of the party you get more
backlash when you fall out of line you
know
yeah i mean we can talk one of the
things we're going to talk about uh
upcoming well we can talk about it right
now which is what happened in washington
last week with the
uh giant bills yeah
when i first met you you didn't seem to
care about what was going on in in dc
that often you were more focused on like
automation tech and that's right and now
since you've gotten into politics you'll
be you're like updating me like you see
what's happening do you see right now
this is a mess and i like it it's been
fun to like grow with you or watch that
journey but
you've been passionate about this both
the infrastructure bill
and i guess passing a budget and the
inability
my my favorite thing that's happened as
a child tax credit it's like the
greatest thing
we actually had a hand in that too we
don't
we're gonna brag about this now we
actually helped we actually did a lot on
that both we being humanity four and the
work that uh liam and the team are doing
there but um
it was because of legal issues we didn't
we it was actually um
illegal to talk about humanity forward
too much because the legal structure it
is versus the campaign but we were very
back to the involvement lobbying
congress for a lot of cash relief yeah
so child tax credit is the greatest
thing ever i i'm certainly a huge
proponent of keeping that around forever
yeah but what um so thoughts on what the
hell's happening on capitol hill right
now no i i was fascinated by it zach and
i will say that there was an instinct i
have that it's hard to get a ton of
momentum around one of these processes
where people are staying late and
there's like this deadline and whatnot
and then when you go through that
deadline and you don't actually get the
bill
then i i do think it's like a bit of a
letdown um and a bruising for people
because then it's like okay i want to do
this again
um let you
i hope
they pass a bill that makes a big
difference in people's lives and
uh it's obvious to everyone that if the
democrats don't pass this bill it's
going to be terrible for them
politically moving forward so you would
think with that as the backdrop
something
will pass because it's
in their interest to do so
but if you project forward and this is
something that there's been a lot of
reporting around there's a lot of doom
and gloom in the democratic party about
what's coming down the pike in 2022
which is going to make it such that
republicans probably retake the house
and then what's going to get done so
this is like the window of time
where they can get as much done as
possible and then if they get something
done that people like then maybe they
can take that case to people in 2022 and
maybe stav off the loss of
it's only maybe four or five seats that
they have as an advantage right now
right
on another note yeah imagine being up
for re-election every two years i feel
like you would have absolutely no time
to do anything before you were back in
it again especially if you're in one of
these competitive seats well you talked
about this with justin amash on a
podcast while back where you're like you
get in there and you're just smiling and
darling for the party pretty much um if
you're if you're a member of congress if
you're sorry if you're a representative
you're fundraising all day every day
that's your job and they all want to be
either a senator or something else
because they see it as a stepping stone
and by the numbers most of them can't
um
so it just sucks and then you probably
imagine if you're there you start to
cling on to what you got which is either
a
congressional committee or appointed you
know what have you been appointed to or
the seniority
like
like structure there i don't know but it
sounds miserable especially if you're
like a wide-eyed millennial or young
hungry a lot of press around you
congressman or woman you're get man you
can't do anything
um
yeah it's a bear yeah um so do you think
i guess prediction what happens in
congress so brad like you've got
we talked about this earlier like
um i guess where do you think do you
think the democrats actually get this
together or um
i think october 18th is the deadline for
to pass a budget like what are we what
are you predicting next couple weeks
you don't get a great feeling um because
it seems like the republicans are
full-on
count us out of anything like a
obstructionist
uh there's the debt limit
which by the way i mean like it the debt
limit
doesn't actually keep us from incurring
more debt and what it does do is
raise the possibility of calamity every
once in a while like it's really not
very helpful
to suggest
uh i mean the best guess is the
democrats get it together and pass
something um certainly the
infrastructure bill and then the
reconciliation in some form
if they don't it would be
catastrophic for the party so you'd
think they would do it
let's say you were a young congressman
from new york let's say
and you were in there is there anything
you would do different
like knowing how the system works a bit
do you think you could have any impact
getting that i mean would you change
your party line like i mean you know go
against party line like is there
anything you could do or is it so beyond
one good person at this point
the best thing you can do is try and
join a little caucus that's going to do
something productive because one
individual member of congress doesn't
matter right and but if you get a group
of a dozen or so then you might have
some real sway
so you'd either join one of those groups
or if it didn't exist maybe start your
own i mean i talked to a member of
congress who started an ai caucus which
i thought was interesting and exciting
to me the problem is that the
system is in the midst of some version
of
uh faltering all the way to collapse and
one of the things i said to van today
which is which i think is really
important for people to understand um
and and this is one
level on which i understand the rancor
toward me for leaving the democratic
party is that democratic party has
become the de facto party of
institutionalists saying hey it's
working it's working we're gonna make it
work pro establishment pro-society yes
anti-anarchy yes yeah and the republican
party has become the anti-institutional
party and one emblem of this is the fact
i cite in my book that 69 of democrats
have a high trust in media and 15 of
republicans do so the republicans are
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] this i don't believe
you you're on my tv screen whatever and
the democrats like no no believe believe
i believe you don't don't you believe
right and so the the there are two
problems for democrats number one they
end up being responsible for these
faltering institutions that do have
problems and you know are
creaky and problematic and so everyone's
like oh gosh then you're like no no it's
working so that's one big problem for
for democrats but then the other thing
is that if you're facing this
anti-institutional energy then you're
you end up just sitting there seeming
like you're an apologist for the status
quo which is a very very bad place to be
particularly in a time when everyone's
pissed off and sad and the rest of it
so you have this very unfortunate
dynamic and so this is one way i
understand where democrats like no no
you can't leave the battlements because
we're like defending the last
hope of civilization right and then and
and so i look at that and be like okay i
understand why you feel that way
um
and to me the job should be to try and
make a system where you don't feel like
you're defending the last vestige of
civilization because
you know what i mean like that that's
or someone else put it to me in a
language said like you have
disintegration versus manage decline
which do you choose and you're just like
well i'd rather choose neither of those
two things like i'd rather choose
something that's kind of
like positive and
and will actually solve the core
problems rather than you know choose
this thing that isn't clearly isn't
leading us in some awesome
trajectory uh and you could you know
blame a number of things for that so
so that's the backdrop and to me the
forward party has the potential to be
the positive
outside the institution's energy you
know what i mean like it's not the case
that every person who's angry at the
establishment
uh is wrong you know like they're like
very very legitimate reasons yes well
you look up and be like
yeah like that is messed up like you
know like you are kind of dishonest you
are kind of bought and sold you are kind
of power hungry your incentives are
cutting the opposite of mine yeah like
these things are true on both sides for
sure
uh and so i think that that's what i
would like to provide is this positive
populist
outside of the institution's energy to
say you can be mad at what's going on or
sad and not be someone who's about to
tear it all down right now
one of the things that i obviously
believe in very strongly is something
like universal basic income in part
because if i was in control of all the
institutions one of the things i'd want
to do is not pretend that the
institutions can do things they can't do
you know like if i was in charge of the
government i'd be like you know what i
am confident we have the power to do
send you money
i'm confident with the power to do that
if i said i'm confident i'm going to fix
your schools it's like i'm not really
sure i'm going to be able to fix your
schools i'd love to be able to fix your
schools i mean let's get after that but
you know like we're going to make
incremental progress in some places et
cetera et cetera so you know like we
need like uh
uh uh
come to jesus like honest conversation
with our institutions about like okay
what can you do and what can't you do
like why are we all so mad why are
people and and this is one of the major
challenges of the democrats that they
they had trump as their
uh
their
uh rallying cry said hey let's get rid
of this guy right and then get rid of
this guy and then you're in there and
then everyone's like why do things still
kind of suck
like you know like i thought after you
beat trump like wouldn't all this look
like the border yeah
why don't we solve the problem when i
feel good and the rest of it and then
they're like yeah not so much actually
[Laughter]
so that
so that people are like well now what
like we're gonna do and so if you did
have a binary dynamic
you're not being set up to succeed
really
because you're you're on like a very
very tough side of this so we need a
dynamic shift where people can again
have something that is going to bring
them hopefully in a positive direction
like a practical direction a
solutions oriented direction and make
the system just much better more vibrant
more modern
more resilient
more genuinely representative
it's a tall order but
it's genuinely in my view one of our
only real paths forward right
[Music]
i'm a huge fan of trying to do what
we're designed to do as humans and you
know what we're not designed to do stare
at a screen all day which is
unfortunately what a lot of us are doing
and as a result we're getting eye strain
we're getting headaches and i'm happy to
say that there is a solution for this
felix gray glasses are the blue light
glasses that started it all they filter
out 15 times more of the blue light so
that you can stare at a screen all day
if you have to and actually be perfectly
healthy i know it sounds too good to be
true i'm actually friends with the
founders of this company and i am pumped
to be able to recommend them on the pond
because they work they like it's
generally they look good too it's
freaking awesome the glasses are either
non-prescription or prescription
whatever you like get them at
felixgrayglasses.com yang that's f e l i
x g r a y classes dot com slash yang
free shipping free returns free
exchanges felix
grayglasses.com again personally
recommend them know the founders great
builders great company great product
gonna keep you healthier which is
something i love to do you know again we
don't wanna have to stare at these
things but we gotta so might as well be
healthy doing it
[Music]
one of the things i'm curious your
thoughts on is the forward party and
your efforts are going to be start
starting to target a lot of independents
and disenfranchised republican
forwardparty.com um
thank
democrats
the
i've been studying a lot on the
attention economy and like and what's
basically the attention economy is that
right now every single brand and
institution from politicians to
coca-cola i mean you name it they're all
uh competing for our most valuable asset
which is our attention and we have so
many inputs on our attention that we've
stopped and by just
necessity started tuning everything out
and politics for a lot of people when
the system isn't working for them it's
something that a lot of people tune out
and i think there's this misnomer both
the left and the right but i think it's
more prominent on the right at least in
our circles where people are like oh
they're just listening to fox news all
day long fox news is the number one
cable news site right now and they're
averaging 1.2 million viewers a night 75
million people voted for donald trump
now you can maybe argue there's a
trickle up effect and there's more it's
obviously bigger than one point million
1.2 million people that are you know
touching fox news
but it's not 50 million right it's not
it's not everybody a lot of people have
tuned out or they're getting it on
they're getting in front youtube or
their friends
and they're just saying middle finger to
the world i'm not listening to any of
this noise thoughts on both that and
also how you start to cut through the
noise
one of the things i want to do is try
and reach people who aren't that into
politics
and so
what are they into maybe they're into
sports
maybe they're into music
maybe they're into
pro wrestling you know like i i like
just you got to reach people
where they are and this is one thing
that i would love this podcast to
develop into is something that reaches
people in different walks of life and
maybe not just this podcast at this
podcast of the wonky
but i think that there's a need for
an independent
media constellation that's reaching
people in different ways and positive
ways and help bring them in a good good
direction help them make sense of the
world
and
there is a real problem where i have
friends who say to me i have no idea
where to go to get my news anymore
and
that something a lot of people feel
uh it's one reason why i think some
independent voices like crystal and
sagar are doing so well because people
trust them and i would love to see much
much more of that i want to be someone
who provides that i want to find other
people who want to provide that and i
want to build that up into its own
media universe
and i think that would be a massive
service to a lot of people and ideally
ford could stand for that right or it's
where it's
truly independent not bought i mean you
talk about this with crystal a bit too
yeah totally and they can yell at me if
they want i don't really care you know
that's one of the other men of what you
do man you go to a bodega
or whatever well you know what i mean
like it's not like forward parties gonna
have like their thumb being like you
said something mean about me
out cast you out you know i'll be like
yeah fine whatever and yeah that's true
grace and forgiveness is a as a tenant
um so a lot of the noise around
the forward party and the rest of it
just goes straight to trump like trump
is still somehow this dominant force in
every narrative it's like oh you're
going to help trump win yeah and the
brewery's gone up
since he's left by the way yeah it's
dark anyway um so my
my thing is look
we have an entire cycle before trump i
mean let's get some awesome people
elected uh and i have my eye on a few
people we're gonna have some fun and
i'll elevate them and do our best to
help um so just saying trump trump trump
is you know not um to me
necessarily productive uh and it is
interesting how that that seems to be
like the primary messaging on both sides
but i will say i'm of the opinion that
trump is the most likely
person to
represent the republican party
in 24 if he decides to run which he
probably will
and
at least two of the major candidates
i've heard have already said either
publicly or privately that they will not
run against trump that's ron desantis
and nikki haley
the people that look like they will run
against trump no matter what are chris
christie
larry hogan mike pence i'm going to
suggest that trump probably defeats them
he has 65 approval rating among
republican primary voters it's a lot
higher than these guys it's gotten more
uh oomph and attention
and it's i think why ron desantis and
nikki haley are like yeah i'll set this
one out for a cycle so you have trump
coming back on that side
and then the democrats and i'll go into
this in in some greater length but the
democrats probably run joe again he's
the incumbent he defeated trump
and i do think a lot of americans are
going to look up and say wow we're doing
this again
four years later like i i think that's
going to be real emblem for the
dysfunction of
our current system in the institutions
right where
you can again act rationally and wind up
with very very
negative outcomes
and that's what we're seeing we're
witnessing
so i'll talk a little bit more about
what i think is coming down the pike in
2024
but that to me is not a reason to just
sit still and do nothing and then be
like oh like
you know like the reason what we should
be doing is trying to make our democracy
more resilient as quickly as possible
and that if you had
open primaries and ranked choice voting
in a bunch of states around the country
i think it would improve things
dramatically i think that it would
actually diminish the chances of
any
person coming in and just running
roughshod on
various democratic institutions like the
fear is real
it's just i'm confused by the approach
other people are taking
the approach that approach being we'll
just line up behind joe again or kamala
if joe doesn't want to run
yes
that if the thinking is like hey
as long as we all get behind joe again
then we can fight off trump and and then
what you know like there's going to be a
successor to trump at some point like
there has to be you know there has to be
a systemic approach at some point
and
uh i'm going to make the tough
observation that
again i think dems are going to have a
hard time mustering the same level of
enthusiasm
the next time around
and
joe beat trump by a lot in the popular
vote yes
but
if you look at a handful of the swing
states the margin was only 42 000 votes
in
states it was close
so if you have any kind of enthusiasm
gap and the rest of it and uh you know
it's it's going to be very very tough
sledding so
with that as as the
likely scenario
i mean there are different approaches
you could take one would be
shut up and you know line up behind joe
and like part of me is like okay i'm
sympathetic to that sort of
but then the other is like hey let's
actually try and fix the system itself
and the time we have
[Music]
well if you're also not thrilled with
what the democrats are doing right now
when they do have majority senate and
house
um which leads us back to what the
democrats can deliver on right now right
yes
which is why they have to deliver
because imagine campaigning being like
hey vote for us and we had power and we
didn't deliver so so they have to
what were the biggest drivers to getting
democrats to vote in 2020 it was
we hate trump and i think coronavirus
right like like a lot of people were
like all right trump
even if you like didn't mind trump
you're like i'm not loving the
leadership we're seeing here well this
is one of the other very very tough
things about where we are right now and
this is what polarization is driving and
uh it was i believe michael schuman
uh in politico who said there's a fear
that we've entered a postmodern age of
politics where facts on the ground don't
matter because we all just get news from
different outlets yeah and so uh it's
almost immaterial what democrats pass or
don't pass
because
the the people who are
polarized against it will just ignore
anything that happens and then that
people like it's a very dark decision
but
you know there are a lot of people that
are trying to agree with that
uh that
right now there's a low policy
correlation between
who i support electorally and what
policies i actually want the correlation
is only 0.25
ah so you already have i didn't know
that really yeah that's terrible yeah so
you might do nothing so when you talk
about the tribalism of politics and
whatnot it really isn't like oh i'm for
you know like this approach to taxation
i'm for that like
most people
everyone in the us wants lower drug
prices right i mean it doesn't matter if
you're a conservative or right liberal
so
with that as your backdrop it it does
make you pessimistic
because if it's just tribalism and teams
i think it's it's going to be hard
for
the dems to to again muster the same
level of energy
based upon policy victories with the
only exception in my opinion being
something like the child tax credit
because because if someone is getting
checks that's real that's direct that's
concrete and if you stand up and say hey
you know those checks you got that's me
that will make a difference that's what
i was gonna ask you on the trail when
you're running for president you talk
about a lot
giving folks a thousand dollars a month
will actually feel something tangible
the government's done for me you start
to create a mindset of abundance
the
administration objectively has given out
a lot of money um
trump gave out some put his name on it i
don't know if the administration slapped
their name on it but i'm not sure um
well one thing i've said is that the
biden administration should every 15th
of the month from now until the end of
the year get up and say hey you know
those checks you're getting 70 million
of you
that's awesome we love them i agree and
they should just have everyone in every
district just have a freaking event
every 15th to be like hey checks are
going out look at all these families
doing great stuff right i thought they
should have a theme for each one where
november could obviously be thanksgiving
or you know october would be halloween
like you'd be like hey the kids are
going to have costumes they're like hey
there's going to be turkey on the table
like you know it's like that's the kind
of thing that americans will
sense in their hands
and feel it um that to me can pierce
through the noise like just about
nothing else
i think
and you've gotten this question a couple
times
i wonder if one of the reasons they're
not trumpeting it is because there's a
worker shortage big time and yeah the
child tax credit is not affecting that
so much it's really that it's
unemployment over time all right yeah
and there the issue you had said is that
when you tie these checks to strictly
not working
you end up with people don't have agency
they just either work and they get a bad
job and little pay or do nothing you and
i know people who are in this boats act
and they're very rational they're
looking up being like look i'm not gonna
work because i'm getting paid
500 a week right now to not work and so
you know like that would be kind of
unreasonable for me to work yeah and
that that's
normal
that's one reason why in my mind making
it unconditional would be much better
agreed
um
so and probably in in some measures
probably a little bit lower than what
some people are getting agreed um or at
least vary by city or state or
level um
all right so
you've got a big
i'm shifting gears you got a big uh you
got a book tour man um which is gonna be
challenging and interesting and covid um
but your goal was actually not
and i'll say this this isn't a great way
this i mean i guess some people find
this a great way to sell books i find it
i think in looking at the numbers it's a
great way to kind of reengage
um a lot of people we haven't seen in a
while around frankly a new type of
vision is that an accurate way to put it
you think yeah it's just getting out
there seeing people signing some books
uh um
i'm excited to see everyone go to
andrewyang.com events um by the time
this airs we'll have eight cities uh in
the offing and i'm coming back to
des moines which will be fun i'm heading
to chicago and philly
and san francisco and atlanta
boston this weekend right yeah boston
this weekend come on out boston
so uh we're everywhere i've gone i
haven't gone to that many places um
during this past period but everywhere
i've gone i've seen
old friends from the campaign i've seen
people who are pumped i've seen people
who understand we need to do something
different this time around
and that they're excited so i'm excited
to see you
join us
no uh we're gonna have a great time we
can talk about some of these things
greater length and depth
uh yeah i can't wait to get out there
and it's intimate too you're gonna
anyone who comes buy a book um hang out
with andrew but you'll stay you'll sign
books you'll take photos oh yeah for
sure it's like q a yeah that's one
reason why these venues too because like
if you did something at a bookstore
which has its plus and minuses you're
not really going to have that long in
exchange with someone yeah it's going to
be like funneling people whereas in this
case you show up you can actually take a
seat we'll have an experience you know
spend
an hour unpacking some of the ideas in
the book
and then i'll sign books and then we can
have the bookstore experience plus
like this extended
uh conversation and i think there are
going to be tremendous events there
they're going to be awesome people there
that want to move the country forward
it's going to be awesome great so it's
andrew yang.com you find everything find
the book find a podcast
you find
book tour
find forward party info yeah it is so
fun zach because you know um thanks to
you like we made a real splash running
for president and we set up humanity
forward which is continuing to do
awesome good to this day yeah
and then now we're starting the forward
party which is going to enable us to
elevate candidates and open primaries
and right choice voting on this book i
am so proud of the fact that we just
keep on making good things happen
and you know some people look at it and
are just like oh
you know
um
i'm not sure what the the thought is
because i feel like most people in our
shoes probably at this point would
um go back to
uh some of the things we've already done
you know but we're like continuing to do
new things and break new ground and i
love it because we need it you know what
i mean it's like
it's one of the things that
jazzes me is that
we're at a tough tough time in american
history right now and
we all feel it we all sense it and then
the question is are we going to do
too much or too little you know what i
mean like like i'd much rather be the
person who's trying to stretch
and make amazing things happen make
unbelievable things happen that some
people don't even think are possible
like that that excites me it's like when
people like oh oh can't be done blah
blah blah i'm just like just wait and
see wait and see because if enough of us
get together we can shock the world we
can actually make a huge difference in
people's lives and i can sense the
energy around
us rising it is really awesome and
exciting and i'm so grateful to the
people who've stuck with the pod i hope
you're gonna love this new era we're
gonna have a lot of fun uh the
production values are gonna be higher i
gotta admit like i know like you know it
was like uh some of like the
video backdrops weren't like nothing to
write home about it's still not our best
work we got like the whole studio isn't
even set up this is our still makeshift
so you can actually see the light in the
background if you're watching on youtube
it's gonna be fascinating conversations
it's gonna be fun
uh kicking productive positive
consistent vibrant from the road
from home uh yeah it's gonna be a blast
i can't wait uh to get started all right
thank you guys for tuning in
see you on monday
[Music]
you